[Music]
morning time I never done anything this
are goddamn
welcome to terraria oh god that thing is
trying into my house and you got funny
vignette I watched some videos of
terraria people make some cool [ __ ] in
this game I mean really so cozy this
game is huh I'm like you know nothing
like having zombies beating up your
showing what a lot of people didn't say
they have this storage in their ground
someone want to try and do that people
say this game is not about building I'm
like wait but that's like the best part
so far my house needs to be beautiful
you don't understand
yeah we're probably my cactus chair take
it out with a char okay say what you can
deer is a bunny it's gonna die rest in
peace bunny I love you oh he's right
you'll live on forever
get slime alright you'll live with me
now so people put their storage here oh
god why are you so hard to remove okay
I'm clearly doing something wrong I need
a hammer no I just punched out the wall
how do I get it up remove the items oh
it's not like minecraft that makes him
just have to place the chairs and
whatever the hell this is
oh god pick it up I got it okay finally
this is so wonky what am i doing okay I
can play Z there nice see that's kind of
cool
right you guys are not seeing me on face
cam my face is helping puff any morning
I look like a literally this green ball
of slime I just want a kir tower to be
beautiful that's really all I care
that's not what I want oh my god the
bunnies they just had to put them in the
game I can make a mana crystal cool
campfire that's cool
can you walk through it yeah so this is
chillin by the fire so when does the
salesman come the bottom room is too
small for salesmen are you telling me I
need to make it bigger die how do I use
it
nice thanks guys it makes sense that the
base is a Lal bigger
no hobo what does that mean why did I
get a no hobo achievement
oh look who made it in huh look what the
cat dragged in table and chair on each
floor why
oh he cleaned this room I need to make
another one
what if I don't want I'm Connor in here
this housing is suitable already
occupied suitable missing table and
chair oh okay cool now we know the truth
suitable nice dirty food if I'm painting
in my house get the [ __ ] out of here
Connor also now I can't build because
this is high hiss you better make this
place good look good okay you better to
make this place look good it's gonna be
the greatest tower of all time just wait
one thing I'm learning about terraria is
just do it right from the sorry
I heard someone use the door Darius
welcome grandpa well coyote come on
I'll Fred get you ass in here outbreak
sexy beast I knew they would come you
wait and you get rewarded that's just
how it is in life can Alfred die
I sure hope not I'd be so sad if
anything happens to out afraid what
would I ever do by myself that's kind of
cute Alfred get the [ __ ] in Jesus come
on
he doesn't want it what do I do
showing my doing he doesn't like Conor
is it Connors issue I can feel it it's
the problem I hate Connor I hate his
guts I want him out of my house all
right that's good enough I can't be
bothered to change all of them this
floor will be uneven and then the rest
will be fine all right let's talk to
Alfred nice okay so now we can I can buy
a sick good that's sick piggy bank
what mining helmet okay I want to sell
you
there have a spare furnace no I don't
anyplace or should I sell him one silver
nice cactus chair no value are you
kidding me he doesn't buy blocks hate
you just telling a bunch of stuff I
don't know what it is no value you know
what has no value you okay well I guess
I can buy piggy bank bug net is that
good I think that's good I'll buy that
piggy bank is too cute enough to have a
makes sense to have all this stuff
together cactus share gets a home of
course here so bug net you can catch sup
Wade right how does that work
oh hey caught a squirrel can I eat it
caught another one consumable that's
awful alright let's eat it you were
supposed to die you were supposed to die
come back here brah I'm trying to cook
you God
oh yeah I want to place the piggy bank
there perfect extra storage the plus at
all okay can they not leave you if I put
them there come on in guys yeah you too
laughs right what's up we're just gonna
chill here
nope okay all right fine time to head
down there's a bunny drowning epic no
God these things are scary dude how do I
get a better weapon at this point
perhaps the sickle the oh god I'm dead
Oh God
oh god I didn't can see Jesus Lord are
you kidding me oh I came to my [ __ ]
house huh Conner illegal get him Connor
yeah do nothing Alfred thank you forgot
to close the door no knock back on the
bow guess the sword is better all right
let's try it
each that's what I thought I can't the
demon ice are so annoying
oh it jumps the bad stabbing a fool I
yeah give me all your shoes okay
these are kind of a Hey
see they come to my pinky nails after
hey you hey I hate you don't kill steel
Connor don't kill seal why did I say how
much rope through I'm gonna help you
guys never dig straight down is what
they say things are about to be a bit
different
dig only two way down it's faster what
are you smoking
yeah but this looks better oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah what the are you doing here
that's how the miners did it back in the
day isn't it
alright I'm gonna gonna be right back
bye bye hey don't good morning gamers
welcome back to the terraria I love this
game I'm so hooked on it alright so
today we're going to hell
because now we have the nightmare pit
gags yeah that's so cool Felix I know
that's the first thing I thought when I
started playing this I'm like whoa
wouldn't be cool if you can go to health
now if anyone ever tells me hey Felix go
to hell I can be like yeah bruh
I've been put on sunglasses yeah I know
I know where's my king gun where's my
gun
holiday I'll murder your family like
where is it you throw away stuff with
tea why would I ever press that oh god
it must be down here somewhere
oh god I used it here what an idiot
jumps into lava who would do that why do
I have Connor in my inventory you are a
terrible person
what would a guide ball yeah I know that
Connor is a terrible person
it quickly ball what does it do I better
not die from any stinky lava is that
llama this it's not lava I'm so confused
okay this is safe lava I don't write the
book on lava but apparently this is
safer lava the other lava however bad
lava that's what happens like Connor
Connor don't say a word
what the hell are you okay here we are
back in hell
you know what I'm gonna do this better
not be some other minecraft wrestling
it's one of those days alright here we
are back in hell
click the bed I was trying to click the
band let him sleep in hell this better
not be a Minecraft reference I can't
sleep in it I think it needs like go
away demons I'm tronic chill I think I
might need to build that a little house
here Connor I hate you alright here we
are back in hell now I should be able to
sleep it's it's not a cozy place to
sleep I don't understand what the it's
my characters problem alright let's go
here
don't touch the lava we should be fine
trying hard not to die that's the goal
in life isn't it for some at least okay
building a bridge I don't care about the
consequences I'm no no I'm out of bridge
material why am I on fire I'm on fire
why am I on fire oh god I can't be in
there it's too hot uh okay we're taking
it the step by step easy peasy no way
I'm gonna die no way out of question so
far this is going great
so much space as well I love I love hell
oh wow
it gets better and better Oh God oh I
can't you guys think I can mine that
corner I need water
alright we're back in action so much
space here did I reach the bottom I
think I reached the bottom yeah I did it
okay why did I do it well I did it it's
like hitting rock bottom do I celebrate
did I beat the game now is that what
happened I think I can't go in here nope
I burn up this is blow up the whole
place oh yeah
bro where is satan disappointed not
gonna lie so I think this is safe Lama
all right I think we're done here
screw hell and screw you Connor or she
went to hell don't even talk to me
Connor all right we're gonna go to the
jungle instead that's right that's not
what right it don't stay a frickin word
Connor demon Skye
whoa is this how to make it or what it's
a weapon
that's so cool okay so maybe he'll
wasn't useless
look at this bunny okay let's head out
desert bang that okay we're in the
jungle gamers hey all right what do we
got I think these are better than the
less I am wait what is this bye
oh god I'm dead
god I'm poor health suck it wait what is
this whoa there's honey blocking
minecraft okay now I'm just sorting two
thing minecraft is copying terraria but
okay I don't like the jungle I changed
my mind about this place
it's dangerous people get hurt I don't
know what hurts me half the time what
the hell is that I'm definitely gonna
drown
[Music]
oh yeah baby
why is it called rich mahogany why
mahogany got a flex on me like that I
legit on the home still alive Oh God
good oh cool
well there's two next to each other are
you kidding me
don't mess this up Felix do not mess up
but babies yes give me this is the
reason I went to the jungle to find
these yeah another one
suck suck more breathing can read what
where I put it
wait if I hold it I can breathe in the
water oh it's like a straw Connor Connor
listen here I'm done with you and your
attitude done don't even talk to me I
think I still have enough to actually
make the laser gun again I do give me
back my gun oh I know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna go to the old man and kill him
murder for fun that's right and I'm not
afraid to kill an old man dude so many
stars look at this look at this look at
the lookie oh my god legit I never seen
that many oh god what is this stop stop
wedding you can't stop me
I mean Jay says somebody stars oh I hate
corruption area this can suck when do
they not just stop spawning you're
annoying and no one likes you and you're
ugly mainly you're ugly hey star do you
think ugly people realize you know I'm
saying alright here's my house my second
home spawn point set
alright where's the old man come back at
night kidding me where should I go I
don't know what to do next I'm not gonna
do something random oh wait there's more
over here yeah screw the old man oh yeah
I have this now I have a breathing straw
wait there's a when I saw a guy sleeping
mate
it's no treasure at the bottom where'd
he go
oh there is oh it builds like that oh I
can't close it to him
wakey-wakey got him I saw this bright
orange colorful fish in the ocean wait
what is he it's supposed to be
underwater go catch it for me so that
anyone will show up looking frantically
instead caught in ocean how do I get
thing I have to make a fishing rod she
says well he drum from drowning I'm not
going in the dungeon you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I know what happens
goddamn weebs take the blue book you
guys better not be trolling me alright
where's the blue book I'm not going down
here too far I know what happened last
time
bro I'm not going down stop that ain't
no [ __ ] Burks oh that's a book
Walter Balt I already got this one
that's 40 damaged water ball can suck my
dad that's the one bro it's not even
good I should the water name everyone
knows what there is for cowards it's
getting dark I got to hurry up here
alright here we go we're gonna set this
up I'm building as fast as I can
Jesus I build the greatest British of
all time it's a multi-layered old man
you're gonna die okay gamers it's time
baby alright space gun doesn't work
where is it fine
need ass eat ass all right let me know
I'm not gonna drink that I'm not gonna
maybe I was with that invisibility could
that be good
press B what just happened oh god I'm a
miserable can I do it even your family
miserable the legs are gone the laser
gun Felix I'm panicking why does he
follow me I see about the layers now I
understand don't touch me don't touch me
a sweetie that's don't touch me
old man trying to touch man we're
switching we're switching I don't know
why I'm making annoying noises don't ask
the hands are dead the hands are dead
kill the hand what are you doing books
books books books books books for no
reason looks for no reason
back to Laser bra we we we we we
you're weak son you got nothing yeah
[Music]
that's what I thought that's what I
thought that's what I thought sweet the
victory press of gee thanks for nothing
bra Terraria veteran if Connor was here
for this [ __ ] his pants that was awesome
easy a-z all right now we go down the
basement and his wife let's how would
that works right can I go down go into
dungeon okay now we go down all right
where's his wife
can I get that is that one thing all
right let's see what this weirdo has in
his house I love how many bosses this
game has and it just makes minecraft
look so empty hey what is that why is
there popcorn in the dungeon it's fine
I'll kill popcorn I don't care
seriously why does minecraft not add
more bosses it's so fun WAIS in Popkin
stop I got way too much stuff on me this
is the problem no no okay nice we have
more help there so chests or something I
want to put my stuff away
maybe I'll just throw them in here okay
you can go no okay I think we're good
for now
oh Jesus what in the world is that okay
grandpa got trapped bro is that a
picture of Santa Claus mine that's my
picture of Santa Claus brothers traps
everywhere it requires a key so I'm
supposed to break these candles water
candle hey it bounces
goblin army is approaching in the east
should I go or should I finish here but
I just got here ever literally everyone
saying go I'll get fine cool this is my
home you thought I came ass
okay East fine I'll go hey this couple
is here
there's goblins everywhere oh my god
they remain in my house oh god we gotta
build a shelter shelters oh god they're
too strong they are actually question
stop stop illegal only I can kill Connor
back up brah I need to never go I locked
myself out there's so many of them
oh god okay okay we're blocked up the
entrances
no one could kill Connor but me cowards
oh you can hit food oh god stop just
okay murder murder there's so many can
you do something how did you let them in
Connor oh god there's a hole in ceiling
that's why don't think so
how am I not died yet I don't know hey
Monica Seles
and I max a nurse do something alright
murder
eat ass hey kid common space gun space
gun space gun oh my god Oh gobbling
genocide it's happening oh god I forgot
the helmet - oh yes the rich - I love
killing rich people come on he's trying
to invade the homeland of Ikea only 73
percent cleared oh god I have so much
more murdering to do okay the same thing
okay
yeah yes
goblin army defeated I felt good all
right Connor better can thank me
hey Connor where's my thanks huh it's
gonna weigh my [ __ ] thanks oh you're
telling me how to survive really that's
rich all right where should I put this
painting here we've decorated for Santa
Claus
that's cold Oh see you get one for each
pasta you kill oh that's cool what do I
do with this voodoo doll can I use it to
hurt Connor and down we go gamers what
the heck are you saved your life gamer
whoa all right hey son loves him
mechanical ends friends wire wish what
is this I don't know what to do with you
man it's my bookshelf where the keys
ain't popcorn hey how long that could be
terraria girlfriends I knew it I'm
taking that with me
oh I got a key I think where there's a
guy sitting there thank you for freeing
me we can get along well grappling hook
is that good
rocket excuse me I'm trying to do
shopping tool bag block placement
these are awesome things can you Frick
oh don't go don't go I love you
it's crafting table okay okay let me
also open the chest
I got a shield just oh I know there I
have Cthulhu god these people won't
leave me alone
so where do I put the crap in there is
that better than mine I think my web
sling is bettering this is longer than
well I'm playing how do I do it how do I
do it I'm just guys stop following me it
only works sometimes oh cool
I don't really see a part of the double
jump then oh maybe the point is that
both what is this another Woody doll but
I got too much time bro I got a freaking
shield now how do I combine items other
there
I lost flight vector boots crafted nice
nice okay okay what happened to my
actual boots did it suck up my boots bro
hi your library okay they merge thank
you awesome
murderuss Muramasa what is that whoa
what is this kind of like it
No Jesus Oh God
I need to realize I have fall damage oh
it's like a protection shield we're a
Massa yeah mama
Muramasa Tara titty more msyn another
guy oh my god there's so much stuff oh
god what do I buy aah
there's too many options ok I'll go and
get it but which one Muramasa he's gonna
kill me oh my sir let me drink this okay
I got the table I got the table
Muramasa it's awesome oh god there's a
lot of them there's a lot of them this
place is very busy I'm not gonna like
well what is that oh I gotta stop being
more careful
I'm not wearing Muramasa I remove the
blue candles to make them spawn less
basically okay nice there's a slime nice
come here hey another slide epic all
right
see nearby danger sources Oh
epic another Cthulhu I don't have Venice
I'll check it later
how big is this freaking dungeon dude
don't think so allows to control gravity
but that is at the end godly AK was
separate than me that's terrible
where did it go godly a concept there
all right
whoa haha its piston whoa it's like a
water gun bone wheel there that's what
your mom is
handgun that seems unorthodox what the
hell bro I'm so full
she says there's a lot of them down
there yes yes did i dilute a key or
something
I saw something purple now it's a battle
potion yeah nice I'm dead
come on Felix I got a shadow key oh I
did get a key where is it well I mean
what do I use it
slimey's fallen from the sky all right
I'll go back home this is getting
ridiculous I'm not blind
shut up there's no space for that woman
where's Connor where's that scumbag you
left because the house is broken off and
come back Connor Jesus Christ slimes
have no chance
oh that feels good Connors a scumbag
just [ __ ] leave there you are you
scum bang okay uh I supposed to ask him
about the Muramasa whoa whoa which one
do I want to make this one right
Knights edge sounds pretty good oh so
that's what I need I need a Muramasa I
need to believe chaos and a fire great
sword and that's how I make my sage fine
hey Connor what do you think of this
[ __ ] can I not show him that wood
I'm so disappointed IKEA tower is under
attack
oh my god I feel so good I love them or
a monster I'm Connor I just decide to
change my house he'll stone bar only 10
okay I have that I think I do at least
now I have brick I don't have bar how do
I get house Sun bar I need obsidian I
think I have a couple I don't think any
whoa whoa stop
oh my god what is happening Oh God oh
this is very confusing they might go
into space
Oh God they don't fly a lot do you think
this game is so weird why they're birds
no bird suffer a Kia Tower be like bye
bye
no I ran out last thing I'm doing today
last thing then I gotta go I'm gonna go
to hell and throw Connor in hell
cuz I'm done with Connor and I'm done
with this game whoa last second jumps
okay Connor I don't like you you're a
little [ __ ] alright boom are you
kidding me he limps Connor lives ok guys
thanks for watching see you next time
bye bye
or too long you have been farting in the
corner now you are entering a new era
where you shall craft the home
the hour of our spells and poop grades
is coming
marzia Edgar and buttons need you
[Music]
the timer you will face but crawlers is
all about
when you are seated on the porcelain
throne booty is the game to play I'm not
supposed to have my opinion about that
but the prices
you